well the world is a toilet and we're all
completely but there are still
occasional bits of good news to distract
us from impending doom and here's one of
them
happy 95th birthday Betty Wow man she's
amazing thankfully the reason the
talented and enduring miss white was
trending on Twitter was because it was
her birthday not because she died or
said something racist
he's great here she is with Katie Couric
and kind of cake is that he's 95 he was
the one a proper slice of devil's food
cake not some crappy berry tart from the
Whole Foods deli case betty was born in
1922 so she was alive to see the Great
Depression and the birth of television
as well as the rise of totalitarianism
which thankfully was just a one-time
thing that definitely doesn't have any
modern parallels you guys so we're all
good comedians how's Betty White gonna
celebrate the big nine five Rory
69 a 69 year old all right all right
very good
fine I feel like that oh that's that's a
trend that's your friend is 59 we'll
wait let Channing Tatum come over and
eat that
[Applause]
Jack continue drinking Puerto Rican kids
blood yeah yeah I'm there forever that
way let's say you listen reference